hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the visitor
massacre at camp happy it's not gonna be
so happy once we're through with it
i have terrible jokes so after i got
done playing astro creep which i'm sure
you all watch cause you all love me so
much and watch all of my videos right
cause they're so full of good jokes
anyway so i got all reminiscent and i
discovered
that the visitor has another game and
judging by what i've seen from it
it's not the same as before it is not
a point-and-click style adventure game
it is
just a little bit different you actually
are free
to roam about the woods and kill uh
hello
i i miss the visitor very much because
he's a
horrifying penile like creature looks
like a great night to watch the meteor
showers
we should trek out the mountain to get a
better view are you coming stacy
no thanks brian i'd rather stay here
safe in the tent
there's no way any of those alien
creatures will crawl up my butthole in
this tent
it's gonna be the surefire way to stay
alive in the woods
the animals are more scared of you than
you are of them just the same steve we
should stick to the trails who knows
what's lurking out then they're
in the darkness oh i think we all know
what's lurking out there in the darkness
horrible butt munching monsters
so welcome to welcome to camp
happy so now that the ominous music has
crescendoed
what we do is we walk around and then
press space button to eat
oh okay hey oh
oh oh you think oh
what i'm gonna get you i'm gonna get you
squirrel [ __ ] don't you know what i'm
the king of
you god damn it get get back here stop
being oh
you're a sassy squirrel ain't you you're
you're lucky i don't know how to play
the goddamn game
okay so sneak up behind them that's what
the information
oh gotcha i got little squirrel arms now
you're done i mean you're done obviously
but everything else in this entire
forest is good ow why
ouchies what am i oh
you can't beat me now why do i have fins
it was a turtle
why do i have fins hang on a second
that's illogical
oh well i'm not gonna question it too
much just gonna smear blood all over the
maybe i can spell my name in the blood
oh
no it's not enough well let's assume
those are boobs and move on oh hey buddy
got it oh well i wasn't supposed to do
that
i'll get you birdie oh [ __ ] help if i
actually hit my
target yeah yeah
yeah ah i fell god i'm a terrible alien
oh gotcha [ __ ] i don't think i was
i don't think i did that the rest well
i'm a big birdie now
now no one oh god that that butthole
face
speaking of butthole oh geez
oh geez those
poor mountain lions oh those poor
cougars
oh wow anybody in that tent oh
oh stacy hey stacy oh
my guys are closing a bag stacy
oh stacy oh someone's scritch scratching
on your ten ears daisy
oh god why do they gotta explode like
that
human devoured yeah i got a new high
score on human eating
hi there do you know the way to the
mountain trail
keep heading north and you'll find it
although i've been hearing some strange
noises coming from the forest
so you better be careful they
conspicuously
sound like a creature burrowing into a
human anuse
and then exploding them from the inside
i've heard that too many times in my
life to mistake it so trust me
it's bad news all right so oh well i
guess this guy's gonna be the victim
then
poor guy he's already dead
one okay why am i small again
why am i small i guess it would be less
interesting oh i gotta sneak up behind
me yeah oh no now they're guarded
yeah ah don't get me well now they're
guarded
yeah get back over there oh got one ho
ho
oh [ __ ] okay sneak up behind don't be a
douche yeah okay so i don't think i'm
big enough to eat that boat
oh hi ho
hey okay goodbye so i don't think i'm
big enough to eat that just yet ooh that
little one though
that little one though oh poor little
guy he's dead now
oh no it woke wait a minute how am i
gonna be
oh you thought you could deftly evade
but you could not
okay so now oh but how am i gonna be
able to get back
do i need to get another animal over
here before i can get
oh you're all fubber knock now because i
got the swimming skills
okay so what i need to do is i need to
now i need to get this guy first and
then get that guy oh no wait it would
have been fine either way i'm just
bigger now
i'm just girthier which is exactly what
i was hoping for anyway
i see you in there oh no
am i too heavy for this oh they respawn
that turtle was not there before so
there must be another
bird here somewhere shake the tree get
the birds all out of here
where's me a bird i want a bird the mice
are back
ah i'm smaller now got
oh i'm smaller that's good
i'm a smaller fish type so i i've eaten
the cougar
i'm small now you're in trouble
oh wow
okay i did not expect that to go that
way but okay
i think we're headed the wrong way and
my god those noises they're getting
louder
i'm sure this is north why don't you two
wait here i'll just walk up the ridge
by myself all by my lonesome
with no one to protect me and watch my
butt
literally and figure out where we are
great plan steve
whatever your name is that's a nice bird
that's a nice bird on that ridge whomp
don't mind my wumpage
i got a lot of wumpy rocks and for some
reason i'm still coming in from outer
space
i'm gonna get you i'll get you
i'm just as small as i was were before
so that doesn't help me much
at least now i can swim which is a good
feature
hello excuse me sir
ow okay so that's not gonna work
ah here we go swim across here
get the birdie and get the birdie
you never saw it coming so how do i get
in there
ah up here oh there's a problem for you
sorry you're dead now okay so now i
should be big enough to take on the boar
down below
not quite the mountain lion just yet but
definitely this bore here
oh yeah oh yeah oh hell yeah
oh but now i need to fly oh that's no
good
okay ah but here we go i can swim swim
across here
i need to be able to fly but i can't get
to that one just yet
wasn't there another bird over here oh
well it worked okay it worked so now i
can take on this
mother hump here yeah
all right how do i but how the last step
is just to get through here and i'm
guessing i have to be small to be able
to
do that oops to be able to good thing
you had your head down
i mean not good for you but good for me
oh yeah oh yeah
and that didn't work but i need to be a
scurry roaring beast
oh but i did become a screwing beast
when i ate you
you okay no no
you okay now i am the scurrying beast
damn tiny nick i'm tiny now okay so this
that's actually cool there's some game
ah oh
need to breathe this one off oh boy
hi ma'am did you happen to see a hiker
go past here short guy with a beard
sorry we mermaids don't see a lot around
here
but if he's wandering out alone you
better find him there's something
roaming around scaring all the animals
also devouring people did i mention that
as a mermaid i don't need to worry about
that
i'm just going to keep swimming around
but you guys should watch out
that doesn't sound good hmm
oh no i don't want to kill the otters
the otters are cute i mean everything
else is kind of cute too but
at the same time it's like oh no the
waters okay
ha so this is going to be interesting
because
who knows who knows what i'm gonna need
throughout this adventure
okay oh but it's too big
okay so
for size i need to be flying before i go
there oh or maybe i can oh maybe i can
get back that way
ow oh cool i can okay
ow god damn it stop playing ping pong
with my butt
ow jeez i'm stopping i don't want to die
i don't want to die
okay yeah got you okay so that now i'm
bigger and i can eat that thing now
ow [ __ ] off thank you okay so now he's
dead
but i need to be smaller now need to be
much smaller
here maybe this is going to be small
enough i don't know if this is going to
be small enough
ah okay not small enough so there's got
to be another like
small or maybe i need to be a scurrying
i need to eat that squirrel that's what
i need ah don't don't
don't please don't oh
damn it
[Applause]
that's pulsating and weird womp
okay good thing i got another one okay
that was nice very tasty
there we go okay i needed flying
so now that i have flying i would be
able to get
yeah i'd be able to get over this chasm
here okay now i got it
and get wrecked okay so now that i got
that i can get the scurrying down
and get small enough to go through the
shrubbery
ovary underway okay now i got it let me
just step on the
mangled corpse of that cooker there and
go through here
oh so trepidatious like get that
mermaid you better prepare yourself
because you're about to be devoured
so i gotta slip by this turtle here i
can't eat that
it's like a maze it's a wonderful
delightful maze
full of fun and friendship and freedom
don't mind me oh
we're here hello oh oh no
sorry that's how every horror movie goes
you die
anyone that's swimming instantly dead it
just goes to show
my fear of the ocean is definitely
verified
who's out there don't come any closer i
have a knife
whoa calm down smoke of joy we're just
looking for our friend
i heard terrible screaming there's
something out there you do better seek
shelter these tents they're definitely
going to protect us
i'm scared steve let's just find brian
and get back to the campsite
how about you don't because he's dead oh
that guy's
so dead that guy's so dead oh that guy's
so dead
all right okay
oh it's right there it's so
close right yeah [ __ ] your camp bro ah
don't kill me all right what do we got
raccoon
ow [ __ ] oh there's a hefty log there
that can hold something big
uh but i don't need to be big i don't
need to be big yet anyway
because i'm bigger now he'll
get you oh yeah okay so now i can scurry
through here
oh but that's that's definitely uh
definitely too hefty for me so i can't
go through there so i got to be a small
scurrying beast
there oh dang it but there's really no
way to go after that
because the hefty log doesn't lead
anywhere else
oh no wait there's a bunch of bushes up
here how could i miss that and another
hefty log
get big oh okay goodbye get some wall
get get nice and small
okay now that i got small i just need to
go down over here
through the bushes the bushes down here
go through
now i'm in a new area i can't eat that
but i can eat you
ow you and then the turk grows some fins
for some strange reason
go across the river
sea otter no no please okay no no no no
no no
no so what else
oh duh i just go back around and then
i'm suddenly in the ocean again
oh perfect done wow i went to quick work
man that tent was so flimsy your head
piled right through that [ __ ]
why do you think that could protect you
i wasn't gonna do anything i'm cold and
scared
oh good for you
keep whining everyone's dying
we're protected by the mountain stay and
make a fire i'll hike over the hill and
see if i can find help
yeah split up that's the best way to go
about these things
good job everybody you're doing great
doing so good
so proud of you so proud of you for
surviving for so long
you did it you really did it you did
good all right womp
okay so screw you guys i need that
squirrel like
right away that squirrel will never keep
me coming
oh god both of you i got
both of you
okay so that one's been done nothing
over there and nothing over there
don't mind the moving shrubbery over
here okay so
i'm online okay so i can't go that way
i would need flying to be able to move
here and i don't think i can get that
bird just yet because i don't have any
fishy
fish so there's got to be some avenue
down here that leads to
something else
you got wrecked okay so now
i just go down this way flitter over
here
bye bye everybody don't mind me there's
a flying freak going through the sky
wait a minute but how's this gonna help
me i can't that doesn't make sense oh
i see there's a shrubbery down there
over to the right so the bird is a red
herring
for now like i'll probably need it later
but right now i just need to be able to
cross that bridge and as soon as
it's just something to delay you you go
across that bridge and of course
you're gonna kill it but now that it's
dead you can scurry through the bushes
here
go over here i'm not big enough to eat
you god damn it i thought i needed to
oh i thought i need to go on a diet god
damn it okay
and then habuski then
you can't hide from me all right then
okay now i need that bird now i need
that bird okay now i need that bird
which is right over here
sorry buddy okay now i got the bird i'm
good to go on that i go over the
the chasm to the dude eat the dude
become bigger bird and eat the cougar
then i need to get small
again her mouth is going to get both of
you
okay now that i got those i can finally
go up the pathway to
that lady who did not start a fire man
she really should have started a fire
because that would have saved her from
all this
how did you get impaled by your own
stick
it was a flimsy house stick and how did
i do that
i didn't even know how i did that hello
i need your help please never mind
really really really
oh really oh that's how we're gonna go
about this oh if i knew this
game was gonna be so long i would i
would have done something else i'll be
right back
okay hello goodbye hello hello
oh god hello oh god hello goodbye thank
you
thank you for that why why did you do
that why did you resent me over here
no no oh god damn it you suck
not you too no i'm almost dead
not you too oh my god this is endless
death this whole way
no ah good god
oh thank goodness i can't even get to
you oh no i can get to you
okay so that's a little saving grace oh
god
oh god i'm almost dead i'm so close to
death
please let me live ah okay let me live
please please living oh no i went the
wrong way oh no
hey okay i got a squirrel
i can find safety in the trees
okay so where did i see a bite-sized
creature
was a bite-sized oh yes yes
very yes okay so theoretically
what was the next step up that i could
do i can't eat a marmosat
yet was it true here was there a bigger
one over here oh the raccoons
okay so i got the raccoons my god damn
it i did not do that
okay that's gonna break okay can't do
that but
now i think i'm big enough to take you
on
maybe i don't want to test that theory
though
yeah oh god it's not ah
oh don't do that i'm just trying to get
back
i'm good stop it oh you sacks of [ __ ]
[ __ ] you you're just a bunch of bullies
that's all you are man nature's really
ganging up on me this time
oh oh ah [ __ ] off okay so we need the
scurrying for a little bit longer
can't take on that guy yet can eat the
raccoons but i don't think i get any
bigger
yeah i don't get any bigger why okay is
there something above that guy
that i need do i need to get smaller is
the question i'm gonna assume that's
a frickin no
stop i don't need to go that way cousin
ruckus you're causing a scene
stop stop being a dick okay
coming in for the kill okay got it good
golly okay
okay this one is rough this one is super
rough oh
verb okay gotta burb
that's good them's good eats
so now i just need to get a little
bigger
i don't know how i'm gonna be able to do
that is there anything else here left to
eat i can't eat those things
ah but i can get back and eat you just a
little bit bigger enough to eat the
burbs over here
headburbs oh and you oh my god
that was a rough wow he became the tent
he literally became all of tent
good for him good for him i'm lost and
can't find my friends i think something
terrible has happened
the meteors something ain't right i saw
one touchdown swore something crawled
out
what we have to go then it's not safe
here these are my woods nothing's gonna
run me out of them
we need to find help i'm out here well
you're gonna find
death which is a damn shame because you
seem like a
nice guy i don't know okay so what's the
first steps here well i can't scurry
through there
so i can't get him can't go there
can't get that guy i can't eat him
gotcha okay so now that i got the
scurrying ability everything should be
much easier
than that i could scurry through and get
the water ability
that would be nice uh small i'm already
small but that just means that i'm gonna
have to circle back and get small again
later but at least i can get this fish
for
now give me you thank you
okay so there's another waterway oh over
here
get the turret i can't eat the turret
yet need big
need to embiganate myself oh i can do
that
ha miss me doink
okay did you get you to get you
and then go back this way so now that
i've been embiggenated i'm gonna eat you
and oh dang it i needed the fish or do i
need the fish
oh i need the fish i need the fish god
damn it i didn't mean to do that
now i'm smaller again i need to go back
and literally oh god i gotta go get the
fish again get that again
i'm an idiot i'm an idiot
i'm an idiot yeah yeah yeah okay here we
go again
okay then go straight up this way
headlift no
have left and live and live okay now
that we're big
i'd live no you're not giving up i'm not
giving this up
so now no stop that
so now i need the scurrying to go
through here
ambush oh got it okay so now that i got
this
i can just flap across get the guy and
i'm dern
you shoulda oh no oh no
he got roasted on his own fire oh
there's something whimsical about that
why wow holy [ __ ] that's weird
help me there's something out here i
think my friends are dead listen buddy i
only get two weekends off a year
save your hysterical ravings for someone
who cares now get lost so i can enjoy my
very naked vacation
it's the best way to celebrate life okay
what you got for me
so flying up there water down there big
guy down there
who's gonna take some funkling i gotta
funkle up a storm that's for damn sure
okay
i don't have the scurrying power oh that
was a mistake oh that was a red herring
right off the bat you had a red
herring ready for me unless you didn't
it looks like you did dead goddamn mice
are so hard to grab
okay so that's for later i just got to
get them for later but first
i gotta go this way through the maze
type woods
no i don't need that guy oh yes i do
because now i can get the flying
get him go up here
go up here stretch my butthole so i can
get a little
more speed going get the flappy floops
fly over here ah here we go liberty flop
over here
whoa hey you can i eat you
ah i can't eat you yet no i need
something oh
no oh no oh no
oh no oh no i have just
i just screwed up everything i just
screwed up
absolutely everything oh no i didn't
because now i can scurry
that's good that's good i can scurry now
i didn't screw up everything i
did what i needed to do hopefully is
that what i need yes
i did and god damn it i didn't oh wait
no yes be a little bigger
scurry go through here
hey buddy you want to fight oh that you
shouldn't have done that you're really
you really shouldn't have done that now
i have the water power
go through here down here all the way
around
i can't take him but i can if i eat this
big one here
and then that'll be an okay never mind
then you're gonna throw me the wrong way
because i'm a dummy
nope not that way but first go down here
here go around you ah [ __ ] oh how am i
gonna ah
[ __ ] off with you oh no wait it was up
here damn it i thought it was over there
ah no god damn it no no
no no okay now ah
there we go i swear i hit that button i
swear i hit that button i swear i hit
that button
i thought i did oh no i picked the one
that was a dead end
good for me i'm a big loser in front of
everybody
everybody's watching this and watching
me be terrible at this
great oh joyous day
get eight get eight get
no well
i don't see any difference i think
everything's exactly as good as it once
was so we can just move on
and maybe this is gonna be the last one
oh it is this cave is my only chance
if i can last until morning i should be
able to find my way back
please god that may be safe oh i don't
think so
i don't think so i'm pretty sure i'm
gonna blast through this last level and
you're gonna get your ass
eaten from the inside out
okay where are we starting where are we
gonna start
oh right here good thing that bird
didn't notice anything that's go oh god
yeah oh you're going to be like that huh
well that's how you're going to play
this huh
oh geez okay oh god damn it
okay i'll come yeah there we go ha
ow god damn it okay we're fine
we're fine everything's fine everything
is 100 okay
ah oh god okay lots of lethality on this
one because this
is probably the last one my
goodness this level is big and girthy
so i get this squirrel i imagine
okay so now that i got the scurrying
power i can go up this road
this way okay go through here
get that thing get a little bigger
so now i'm bigger and that was the first
goal that i needed to accomplish i bet
and then i get that bird and i'm gonna
be able to fly further
or at least i'll be able to fly to an
area where it can actually eat something
bigger than i
was able to before hopefully
okay if i fly down here now maybe yeah
oh yeah again i'm a bigger scurrier now
i'm here okay then i can get that
that's another scurrying beast i don't
need that right now
can't go down that way get baited oh
get baited oh and you are eaten
yes yes yes
now i have the power now i am the one
who rules
okay so sploosh plum okay luge
then more scurrying power
go through no eat the void
i'm now i'm a big boy oh now you're
now everything gets eated oh is there
any reason i should do that
no there's not then i just keep going
then
i shouldn't even unless i was just
feeling like it but i feel like it
ruined everything because it would give
me scurrying powers and i don't need
that right now
where the heck's the dude oh he was up
here oh i didn't need to do any of that
i just went on a revenge killing spree
oh man well not the worst one of them
all but
there was a nice scream before that oh
god
oh geez
vicious attacks unlike anything we've
ever seen
horrifying murders well there you have
it
the visitor is
he's back and he's munching on some
innards
and it didn't take me too long it was a
longer game but actually i kind of liked
it so
thank you everybody so much for watching
let me know what you thought of it and
check out the other visitor games that i
played down in the description below
and as always i will see you in the next
video
bye-bye hey
don't wanna mess with me i'm an alien or
we can leave now what are you doing
why are you avoiding all the things that
gives you beats i'm trying